AND A HANDFUL OF EMPLOYEES WERE
INVOLVED.
HE ALSO SAID THIS DOES NOT ANY
WAY IMPUGN THE INTEGRITY OF THE
FBI AND ITS WORKFORCE, BRET.
>> Bret: LET'S GET REACTION
FROM THE CHAIRMAN OF TWO MAJOR
HOUSE COMMITTEE IS LOOKING INTO
ALL OF THIS.
TREY GOWDY IS CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE OVERSIGHT AND GOVERNMENT
REFORM COMMITTEE AND BOB
GOODLATTE CHAIRS THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CHAIRMAN GAUDI, FIRST TO YOU.
JUST OF BROAD OVERVIEW, WHAT
STRIKES YOU ABOUT THIS REPORT?
>> WHAT A DARK DAY IT IS FOR THE
FBI AND DOJ, TWO INSTITUTIONS OF
OUR COUNTRY DESPERATELY NEEDS
AND WE DESPERATELY HAVE TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THEM.
IN THIS LEVEL OF BIAS AND
ANIMUS, NOT ONLY DID THEY WANT
TO STOP THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN BUT
HE WANTED TO STOP THE TRUMP
PRESIDENT.
PETER STRZOK, THE FBI AGENT THAT
WAS ON ELDER CLINTON'S
INVESTIGATION AND ARGUABLY AT
THE LEAD RUSSIA INVESTIGATOR NOT
ONLY WANTED TO STOP HIS
CAMPAIGN, BUT ONCE HE WANTED,
GOT ON THE MUELLER PRO BECAUSE
HE WANTED TO IMPEACH HIM.
THAT'S A LEVEL OF ANIMUS AND
BIAS THAT EVERYONE SHOULD
REJECT.
THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES.
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE THAT YOUR
FELLOW CITIZENS QUESTION WHETHER
OR NOT THEY CAN HAVE CONFIDENCE
IN THE WORLD'S PREMIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY AND
THAT'S COMING FROM SOMEONE WHO
HAS DEFENDING           DEFENDED
HAS DEFENDING           DEFENDET
HAS DEFENDING           DEFENDEE
HAS DEFENDING           DEFENDEM
HAS DEFENDING           DEFENDEA
HAS DEFENDING           DEFENDEL
HAS DEFENDING           DEFENDET
HAS DEFENDING           DEFENDEI
HAS DEFENDING           DEFENDEN
HAS DEFENDING           DEFENDEH
HAS DEFENDING           DEFENDES
CAREER.
THIS WAS A BITTERLY
DISAPPOINTING REPORT.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THIS REPORT
SHOWS THAT THERE WAS SPECIAL
TREATMENT GIVEN TO
HILLARY CLINTON IN THE
INVESTIGATION OF HER CASE.
THERE IS NOT A STANDARD
PROCEDURE FOLLOWED IN
INVESTIGATING HER, AND THERE WAS
SPECIAL TREATMENT GIVEN.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THIS WAS
NOT A PROPER PROCESS AND OF THE
REPORT SHOWS TIME AND TIME AGAIN
HOW DIRECTOR COMEY AND OTHERS
MADE MISTAKES, ERRORS IN
JUDGMENT, OR DELIBERATE.
PEOPLE CAN DRAW THEIR OWN
CONCLUSIONS.
BUT IT WAS ON IMPROPERLY
HANDLED.
AND AS TREY SAID TO COME AND YOU
CAN UP AGAINST OUT THE
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN HANDLED
IN THE SO-CALLED TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION, AND YOU HAVE CONTRAST
THAT IS SHOCKING IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY HANDLED ONE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN COMPARED TO ANOTHER.
IT'S GOT TO BE INVESTIGATED
FURTHER, CHANGES HAVE TO BE
MADE.
I WILL COMPLEMENT DIRECTOR RAY
ON SOME OF THE PERSONNEL CHANGES
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE, THERE ARE
SOME SOBERING LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THIS.
WE NEED TO SEE CHANGES MADE SO
THAT IN 2,020 WE DON'T SEE
ANOTHER PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
HANDLED LIKE THIS.
>> Bret: SO WHEN YOU HEAR
REPUBLICANS AND PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN LOOKING INTO THIS AND SAY,
THIS 568 PAGES, THERE IS JUST
NOT A LOT THEY ARE, OR THAT
HOROWITZ LEFT SOMETHING ON THE
TABLE, HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
>> THIS IS A VERY THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION.
HE TAKES MINUTIA AND EXAMINES
EACH PIECE CAREFULLY, DRAWS HIS
CONCLUSIONS, AND I COMMAND
CONCLUSIONS, AND I COMMAND     C
CONCLUSIONS, AND I COMMAND     M
CONCLUSIONS, AND I COMMAND     E
CONCLUSIONS, AND I COMMAND     D
CONCLUSIONS, AND I COMMAND     H
CONCLUSIONS, AND I COMMAND     M
CONCLUSIONS, AND I COMMAND     .
I THINK IT'S A WELL-DONE REPORT.
I NEVER EXPECTED HIM TO FIND A
RECYCLE THING AS SOME CRITICS
HAVE SAID BUT HE DID FIND ALL
WHEN YOU COUPLE THAT WITH THE
STRZOK PAGE TEXT, INCLUDING THIS
NEW ONE THAT HAS COME OUT
RECENTLY WHERE PART OF IT ROSE
REDACTED, AND BY THE WAY WE ONLY
GOT PART OF THE SENTENCE WHERE
HE WAS GOING TO STOP
DONALD TRUMP OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT'S IMPROPER FOR THE FBI.
PRIMARILY THAT WAS THE PREMIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY AND
BESMIRCHING OF TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN WHO KEEP
US SAFE, PREVENT TERRORIST
ATTACKS AND FIGHT CRIME EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
I HANDFUL OF PEOPLE IN THE
HIERARCHY OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE CAUSED SERIOUS DAMAGE.
>> Bret: LET'S PUT UP THE
AUGUST 8, 2016, WHICH IS THE ONE
WHERE PAGE SAYS TRUMP IS NEVER
GOING TO BE PRESIDENT, RIGHT?
RIGHT.
AND THAT PART WAS REDACTED.
HERE'S ANOTHER PART THAT WE
BELIEVE.
NOVEMBER 22ND, 2016, FBI
ATTORNEY ONE, ISN'T MAKING
RETHINK YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION?
I THINK THAT'S A LISA PAGE.
ATTORNEY TWO, NO, VIVA LA
RESISTANCE.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT'S PETER
STRZOK.
LET ME SAY THIS, JIM COMEY, IN
HIS INTERVIEW HERE AT SPECIAL
REPORT, I ASKED ABOUT THE
STRZOK-PAGE TEXT.
AND IF HE KNEW NOW WHAT HE KNEW
THEN, WHAT HE WOULD DO.
>> I WOULD HAVE REMOVED BOTH OF
THEM FROM ANY CONTACT WITH
SIGNIFICANT INVESTIGATIONS,
INCLUDING THOSE INVOLVING
ANYBODY CONNECTED TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, BUT BEYOND
THAT.
>> Bret: SO YOU'D RATHER THE
WORK PRODUCT THEN BE QUESTIONED?
>> SURE.
>> Bret: THIS DEALS WITH THE
BLEACH BIT AND OF THE SERVER,
SHERYL MILLS AND THAT.
INTERVIEWS MICHAEL FLYNN AND HIS
INTRO: THIS ENTIRE CASE.
>> BUT HE'S ONE OF MANY OTHER
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN ALL THE
THINGS YOU TICKED OFF.
WHEN I SAW THE TAX, I WAS DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED IN THEM BUT I NEVER
SAW ANY BIAS.
>> Bret: ANY BIAS.
>> WHILE HE'S NOT READING THE
SAME TEXTS THAT I AM READING.
PETER STRZOK SAID THE VOTE
SHOULD BE 100 MILLION TO ZERO.
HE CAN'T THINK OF A SINGLE
SOLITARY AMERICAN THAT WOULD
WANT DONALD TRUMP TO BE
PRESIDENT.
HE SAID HE WILL STOP IT.
ACTUALLY, DIRECTOR COMEY
UNWITTINGLY JUST PROVE THE POINT
OF THE QUESTION YOU ASKED HIM ON
FOLLOW-UP.
WOULD YOU HAVE KEPT HIM ON
INVESTIGATION HOW DO YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU KNOW NOW?
AND HE SAID NO.
BECAUSE BIAS IS NOT INSIDIOUS,
IT'S THAT PERVASIVE AND IT
COLORS YOUR ABILITY TO DO WHAT
WE NEED THE FBI TO DO, WHICH IS
TO BE FAIR.
SO OF COURSE, YOU WILL FIRE HIM
THE DAY YOU LEARN.
IN MY HEAD, I GO BACK.
WHEN DID YOU START WORKING ON
THE CASE?
THAT'S WHEN YOU SHOULD HAVE BEEN
FIRED.
SO WHATEVER HE DID ON EITHER OF
THESE INVESTIGATIONS, BRET, IT
HAS TO BE VIEWED THROUGH THE
PRISM THAT HE CAN'T THINK OF A
SINGLE SOLITARY PERSON THAT
SHOULD VOTE FOR THIS MAN TO BE
PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: SO STRZOK'S ATTORNEY
SAYS THIS WAS TAKEN OUT OF
CONTEXT.
DID THEY KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT
THE RUSSIA INFORMATION, AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE REFERRING
TO?
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS CHANGES
AT ALL IN CONTEXT, FOR IN A
VACUUM, IT IS IT JUST?
>> IT CHANGES A LOT GOING
FORWARD.
RUSSIA DID SOMETHING TO OUR
COUNTRY IN 2016.
IT WAS SERIOUS, IT DESERVED TO
BE INVESTIGATED AND IT DESERVED
TO BE INVESTIGATED BY A FAIR FBI
AGENT WHO WAS NOT TALKING ABOUT
IMPEACHING THE PERSON THAT HE
WAS INVESTIGATING.
HIS LAWYER IS JUST WRONG, THAT
BY A STATE IMPACT SOMETHING.
HE WAS SO HYPER FOCUSED ON TRUMP
THAT HE IGNORED AT THE-ABERDEEN
EMAIL AND CAUSED JAMES COMEY TO
SEND A LETTER ONE MONTH LATER
THAN HE SHOULD HAVE SENT IT.
WHY IS IT OUR JOB TO PROVE THAT
STRZOK'S IS BIASED IN HIS
DECISION-MAKING?
YOU COME BEFORE THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC AND PROVE TO US THAT YOU
ARE MANIFEST ANIMUS TOWARDS
DONALD TRUMP DID NOT AFFECT YOUR
DECISION.
>> Bret: LET ME ASK ONE MORE
QUESTION.
>> BECAUSE TREY IS EXACTLY
RIGHT, WE HAVE BEEN REQUESTING
THAT HE BE PRODUCED AS A WITNESS
FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
IF THAT AGREEMENT IS NOT REACHED
WE WILL SHORTLY ISSUE A SUBPOENA
FOR HIM TO APPEAR.
>> Bret: SPEAKING OF THAT,
THERE ARE ALSO DOCUMENTS THAT
YOU WANT THAT YOU STILL HAVEN'T
RECEIVED.
>> WE ARE SETTING UP A BETTER
PROCESS AND WE ARE MAKING
PROGRESS.
WE HAVE A ROOM AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE WHERE THEY ARE
PRODUCING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS AND ARE INVESTIGATORS
ARE PRODUCING THOSE.
WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS IN THAT
REGARD, BUT WE ALSO HAVE OTHER
DOCUMENTS THEY HAVE NOT PRODUCED
AND THAT WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS
ON.
WE HAVE MEETINGS COMING UP
SHORTLY ON HOW TO GET THOSE
ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTS REQUESTED,
PRODUCED.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT
TO KNOW.
AT THE CONGRESS IS IN THEIR
REPRESENTATIVE AND THE DOCUMENTS
HAVE TO BE PRODUCED.
THERE IS NO REASON NOT TO
PRODUCE THEM.
>> Bret: CHAIRMAN GAUDI, THE
LAST TIME YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
FBI INNER WORKINGS, IT WAS ABOUT
THIS ALLEGATION OF SPYGATE.
YOU SAID AT THE TIME, YOU
THOUGHT THAT THE PRESIDENT AND
OTHERS THOUGHT THE FBI WAS DOING
WHAT HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING.
IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS, AND YOU
ARE ANIMATED ABOUT WHAT YOU ARE
LEARNING ABOUT THIS IG REPORT.
ABOUT HOW THIS IS ALL PROGRESS
EVEN WHEN IT COMES TO THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION?
>> BRET, I'M ANIMATED BECAUSE
RUSSIA TRIED TO DENY OUR
FUNDAMENTALS OF 2016.
AND I HEARD WHAT ANY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY HEARD IN
2016, EVERY ONE OF MY FELLOW
CITIZENS WOULD SAY, YOU GO FIND
OUT WHETHER THAT IS TRUE OR NOT.
YOU WILL FIND OUT WHETHER A
FOREIGNER, A HOSTILE COUNTRY IS
GOING TO MESS WITH OUR ELECTION.
WHAT OUR FELLOW CITIZENS ALSO
EXPECT IS FOR THE AGENT THAT
DOES A FOLLOW-UP TO BE FREE OF
TAINT AND BIAS.
IT JUST SO HAPPENS THAT THE ONE
PICKED TO FOLLOW UP AND LEAVE
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION HAS
MANIFEST ANIMUS AND CAN THINK OF
A SINGLE PERSON TO VOTE
DONALD TRUMP.
SO THOSE TWO ARE INEXTRICABLY
INTERTWINED.
MOST OF MY FELLOW CITIZENS WOULD
SAY, I WANT TO KNOW WHAT RUSSIA
WAS DOING TO US IN 2016 BUT I
ALSO WANT THE PERSON THAT IS
FINDING OUT AND INVESTIGATING IT
TO BE FREE OF BIAS AND FREE OF
TAINT.
>> Bret: AND THEY WOULD SAY,
MUELLER, FIRE THAT GUY.
>> AND HE DID FIRE HIM.
THAT'S WHAT'S SO PERVASIVE ABOUT
BIAS, IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
MUELLER COMES UP WITH.
SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BELIEVE
THAT STRZOK'S LEVEL OF ANIMUS
WAS SO HIGH -- >> Bret: THIS
IS WHAT YOU HEAR.
THEY HEAR US REPORTING ON THESE
568 PAGES AND THEY HAVE BEEN
WAITING FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS.
AND THEY HEAR WHAT IS COMING OUT
OF IT.
WHO IS GOING TO PAY FOR
SOMETHING THAT WAS DONE WRONG IN
THEIR MIND.
AND INVESTIGATION AFTER
INVESTIGATION, IT SEEMS LIKE IT
COMES TO A HEAD AND THEN NOTHING
HAPPENS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HUNDREDS OF CLASSIFIED EMAILS,
OR HANDLED IMPROPERLY IN
VIOLATION OF THE LAW, AND NO ONE
HAS BEEN HELD ACCOUNTABLE IN
THAT REGARD.
NOW WE SEE THAT THE WHOLE
PROCESS OF THAT INVESTIGATION
WAS HANDLED WITH EXTREME BIAS
AND A WHOLE HOST OF QUESTIONABLE
ACTIONS, AND PEOPLE NEED TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
SOME PEOPLE ARE NO LONGER
EMPLOYED AT THE FEDERAL BUREAU
OF INVESTIGATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE HAVE TO MAKE A CHANGE SO
THESE THINGS DON'T OCCUR IN THE
FUTURE AND WE DON'T HAVE A 2,020
THAT LOOKS ANYTHING AT ALL LIKE
IT DOES IN TERMS OF THIS KIND OF
MISHANDLING OF INVESTIGATIONS OF
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF IMPORTANCE,
WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
TWO CANDIDATES FOR PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
SO TREY AND I ARE GOING TO HAVE
A JOINT HEARING NEXT TUESDAY
WHERE WE WILL HAVE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND BE ABLE TO
GO INTO THIS 560 PAGE REPORT AND
ASK QUESTIONS.
THE FOLLOWING WEEK, WE HAVE
ALREADY REQUESTED THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES, MR. ROSENSTEIN,
AND THE FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER
WRAY TO COME FORWARD AND TALK TO
US AND ANSWER OUR QUESTIONS
BASED ON THAT REPORT.
>> Bret: OTHER QUICK NUGGETS
HERE, IN THIS REPORT IT SAYS
DEFINITIVELY THAT HILLARY
CLINTON'S EMAILS WERE HACKED BY
FOREIGN ACTORS OF SOME KIND.
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHY THAT'S
IMPORTANT.
>> WE GOT A LITTLE WINDOW INTO
THAT WHEN ONE OF JIM COMEY'S
ORIGINAL MEMO DRAFTS HAD THAT
LANGUAGE IN THERE AND IT WAS
EDITED OUT.
THERE ARE TWO REASONS THEY CITE
FOR NOT PROSECUTING
HILLARY CLINTON.
NUMBER ONE, SHE DIDN'T HAVE
SPECIFIC GENERAL INTENT AND
NUMBER TWO SHE DIDN'T EXPOSE IT
TO FOREIGN ACTORS.
AND ONE OF THOSE REASONS IS
BOGUS.
HAVE THEY DONE A GOOD JOB OF
INTERVIEWING HER, HAD THEY NOT
MADE UP THEIR MIND SIX WEEKS
BEFORE THEY WENT TO INTERVIEW
HER, PERHAPS I COULD HAVE FOUND
EVIDENCE OF INTENT TO COMMIT A
CRIME.
BUT THEY DIDN'T LOOK FOR IT.
THEY MADE UP THEIR MIND BEFORE
THEY EVER INTERVIEWED HER ABOUT,
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
HOROWITZ, AND OTHERS, SOME OF
THE COLLEAGUES THAT UNLOCKED THE
FACT THAT THOSE EMAILS WERE
EXPOSED TO FOREIGN ACTORS.
>> Bret: IF I DID THIS, I
WOULD BE PROSECUTED.
THAT'S IN THE IG REPORT.
>> EXACTLY AND WE FOUND OTHER
EVIDENCE WHERE PEOPLE WERE
PROSECUTED FOR ACTIONS SIMILAR,
CONTRARY TO WHAT THE FBI
DIRECTORY CONCLUDED.
>> Bret: THE FBI CASE WAS SLOW
WALKED?
>> YES, HE SAT ON EMAILS, AND BY
THE TIME COMEY GOT TO THEM AND
SENT THE LETTER, WE WERE ON THE
EVE OF AN ELECTION.
BUT IN SEPTEMBER 1 WHEN HE
LEARNED ABOUT THIS, HE DID
NOTHING BECAUSE HE WAS HYPER
FOCUSED ON STRZOK.
>> AND IF I WERE ANY AMERICAN I
WOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
DIRECTOR TOMMY HANDLED THAT.
WHY WOULD YOU HANDLE THE WAY YOU
RELEASE THAT INFORMATION?
>> Bret: LET ME PLAY THAT.
>> WEEKS WENT BY WITHOUT ANY
ACTION.
>> I DO KNOW THAT NEW YORK AND
FBI HEADQUARTERS BECAME AWARE
THAT THERE MAY BE A CONNECTION
BETWEEN WEINER'S LAPTOP AND THE
INVESTIGATION.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THEY COULD
HAVE MOVED FASTER, OR WHY THE
DELAY.
>> SO DID THAT REALLY DRIVE YOU
TO THE NOT CONCEALED PART?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THERE WAS A
SLOW ACTIVITY, WHY IT WAS SLOW
THIS FIRST COUPLE WEEKS.
>> THERE WAS ONE AGENT AND HE
KNOWS THEY WOULDN'T BE
PROSECUTED ANYWAY.
>> HE USED THE WORD INDEX, HE
DIDN'T PROPERLY INDEX THE FACT
THAT HOUMA ABERDEEN WAS MARRIED
TO ANTHONY WEINER.
HE MAY HAVE BEEN THE ONLY PERSON
IN THE ATMOSPHERE THAT DIDN'T
KNOW THEY WERE MARRIED.
I WAS ONE EXCUSE.
HE CALLED TO WASHINGTON
SPECIFICALLY SAYING, WHAT ARE
YOU DOING AND WHAT'S TAKING SO
LONG?
LET'S WHAT FINALLY GOT HIM TO
MOVE.
McCABE WASN'T MOVING AND
STRZOK WASN'T MOVING.
>> Bret: SOME OF THE TEXT
MESSAGES COULD BE MISSING.
>> WE WILL KEEP LOOKING FOR
THEM.
HE DID A GOOD JOB AND FROM THE
FIRST BIG BATCH OF MISSING TEXT
MESSAGES, AND MADE THOSE
AVAILABLE BACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT, WHICH MADE THEM
AVAILABLE TO US.
BUT YES, WE HAVE ACTUALLY
BENEFITED IN A MULTITUDE OF WAYS
TO THIS INVESTIGATION.
IT'S FILLED AND A PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE BUT ALSO RESULTED IN MORE
INFORMATION COMING TO US JUST IN
THE LAST FEW DAYS AND WEEKS.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT, WRAP THIS
UP.
WINNER AND LOSER IN THIS IG
REPORT IN YOUR MIND?
>> I THINK THE FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION BUREAU AS A WHOLE
IS A LOSER AND I HOPE
CHRISTOPHER WRAY IS TAKING THIS
SOBERING LESSON TO HEART.
HE CAN DO GREAT THINGS WITH THE
PUBLIC'S TRUST IN THIS
ORGANIZATION, AND WE ALL SHOULD
TRUST.
I THINK 99% OF THE TIME, WE
SHOULD.
>> WINNER IS MICHAEL HOROWITZ,
BECAUSE HE PROVES THAT YOU CAN
WIN WITH AN INVESTIGATION.
THE LOSER IS EVERYONE OF MY
FELLOW CITIZENS THAT WANTS AND
FBI AND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT THAT